what i love is is the excitement i love
i hate
cool i hate being cool i'm not cool i'm
not i hate when people try to be
i love you're always a person you wear
your uh emotions on your
whatever you you just like i like seeing
you excited i like seeing a person
excited about what they love and their
dreams coming true
and whatever happens with bogatan
because bocatan is an important part but
um
i just think it's it's awesome and i'm
glad someone like you
got it because you appreciate it so much
you know i've had on my show another
life right now i
i am i made a decision um when i took
this job
that i would be positive every single
day
that i would come to work and i would
be a leader that was
optimistic all the time um because i've
worked
and i have been the opposite you know
i've
i've been the person that needed to be
called out on set for my attitude
um whoa whoa really you yeah what kind
of addict
when did this happen and and what
adjustments did you make so
you know the thing with me as you said i
wear my heart on my sleeve
um i when i'm in a
bad mood i have a really hard time
hiding it and
i had it was the first season of
longmire
i'd come right off of riddick and we
were doing night shoots and i was
exhausted
and i went straight into early morning
days in freezing cold weather
during longmire and season one and um
it was cold and i got sick and
um and bailey chase and i
would drive to work together because we
would
we were always outside the limit which
we about 60 miles every morning
and i would complain all the time
about you know i i just
felt like i was being underutilized on
the show and i was disappointed and i
didn't
um i didn't want to go complain because
god
god forbid you go and actually have an
adult conversation with someone i just
wanted to about it all the time
um and i was also not in a great spot in
my life i was in a relationship
that lasted too long and and i should
have i should have left and i was just
not
a very happy person and
he called me out in front of the entire
crew one day and it was
until this day i you know he and i
finally made up
because it was not good for a while
because i was so disappointed in the way
that he did it
you know my mind was do it offset have
this conversation with me offset don't
do it in front of the crew
um but it taught me the one of the
biggest lessons of my career and i
realized that i had a choice
and i had to change my perspective and i
needed to grow the
f um what did he say to you
in front of the crew he screamed at me
and said
be here want to be here i am so tired of
you
you know and i don't really remember
what he said but it was it was loud and
it was
it was um and i always thought it was
the wrong time in the wrong place i was
very angry that he did it that way
but it needed to happen
and it woke me up and it made me realize
that
that the attitude i bring to set every
day is the attitude
that permeates the set because for
better or worse i
have the ability i think because i'm so
big
and i'm loud and my voice carries like
that i have the ability to change the
set
i can make it a positive place to be or
a negative place to be
and i i
was wrong i was very wrong and i had to
learn that lesson
yeah and i learned two things i learned
i needed to stand up for myself so i
went in and i started talking to the
producers about what i wanted the
character to be
um but i also realized that i needed to
be the person that people wanted to work
with twice
it couldn't be the person that um
took it for granted i was taking it for
granted and i
needed to be called out and he did it
and then
by the end of the the series
the producers all you know said
they would work with me again i i went i
did a complete 180
purposefully but i taught myself how to
to be happy